mean I lost a job because I disbelieved
Meghan Markle there you go with her
claims of racism against the royal
family I said I don't believe it so I
had to leave my job I mean it was
completely insane when you think about
it now I'd be fired for believing it
that's true right that's true I mean
it's true
um I'll get you though my book beat
print you know his his book had come out
earlier number one and then when I
became I was higher than Prince Harry
we're all very grateful what do you make
of those two you have a view of them I
don't I mean you know I think that um I
really respected the queen I mean I
think she was uh really elegant and I
think her stoicism and I think it was
really good you know as the younger
Generations it's a little bit more mixed
I mean that's just the reality
are they annoying I think for some they
are I mean look I'm not involved in that
blue I just kind of focus on but I think
for some Americans they can be